κλογική η οποία είχε χαρακτηριστικά διχαστικά αυτόν ήταν ηουσίααδιότη ήτανε στος σωτερικά τα θέματα υπήρχαν
και σωτερικά θέματα και σίγουρα από τότε πουλόνεται εγώ να το πο έτσι επουλώνεται ι
επούλωσί είναι πουμια ήμερα στην αλλήνη πουλοση θέλει χρόνον εσύ προβληματίζεσε να βλέπει τέτοια δημοσιρεύματα
ότι υπάρχει ουσιαστικά μια γέύτυρα επικοινωνίαέεγώ θησεάμοδεέν εγώ τη θυσέαμου εγώ θα σουμε λήσω ελικρινά
εγώ δενα σχολούμε με αυτής της μορφής την παραπολιτικήαι παραφιλολογία και τα λιπά γιατα λιβά
για ένα αναπλώ λόγον ότι δεν είναι ούτε στη δική μου δεν είναι ούτε ούτε
στο δικό μου καθήκοντά να σουτοπο έτσι δεν είναι όμως ούτε και σττρόπο με τον
οποίο λιτουργό δεν μπορούν να εληθούν προβλήνατα μετνα συζητούμε μεταξύ μας μέσα που τις εφημερίδε
με παραπολιτικά με μάσκα δελαδή για διάφορα θέματα εκτιμό πολύ τα ρεπορτάς διατή βάλλο αξία
πολλήσε ένα δημοσιογράφωνο οποίος αφιερώνεινι χρόνο να συνθέσει μιανικόνα και να μας στην παρουσιάσεις κίνο
κίνων έχει μια ανουσία αφιερώνω χρονώ πολύ σταροτήματα που σου κάνοιον δημοσιογράφει καλήώρα όπως τού
των που έκαμε τορά που που μεταφέρει με κάποιον τροπό που την κοινωνία κάποιακάποια στημία
δεν μπορείς να σχολίσει όμως με τα παραπολιτικά καθημερινά και σου λέω ότι είναι να
πρόβλημα τεράστιώ του τ ούλια τα παραπολιτικά όμως επιδίαρώτησες κάτι και θελα δα παντήσουν δεν
μπορούμε να σταματήσουμε να μεέχουμε σχέσεις ανθρώποι οποί με τον άλφα επείτα τρόποπρον κάποια χρόνιατα
στνήτική